Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
« Et toi ?
Tu fais quoi dans la vie ? »
C’est la question qu’on a tous déjà posée
des dizaines et des dizaines de fois.
Il y a quelques années, j’étais
à une soirée chez des amis
et je ne connaissais pas grand-monde.
Invariablement, la même scène
s'est reproduite.
Un inconnu, appelons-le Gérard,
me demande innocemment,
après quelques secondes de bavardage :
« Et toi, sinon, tu fais quoi ? »
Et bizarrement, cette fois-ci,
la question m’a semblé un peu bête.
J’avais envie de lui dire :
« Ben, écoute, je mange
un feuilleté sec et gras à la fois. »
Bien sûr, je comprenais que Gérard
voulait savoir quelle était mon activité,
ma fonction, ce qui me permet
de vivre et de payer mes factures.
Pourquoi est-il si commun
de se définir par le travail ?
Et pourquoi ça me pose problème ?
Ça me donne la sensation
d’être coincée, d’être figée,
d’être engoncée dans une case
et de ne pas pouvoir m’étendre
au-delà de cette fonction.
Et surtout, comment est-il possible
de se définir par le travail
quand on sait que 85% des métiers de 2030
n’existent pas encore
sous leur forme actuelle ?
Ce jour-là, j’ai réalisé à quel point
le travail a une valeur sociale.
Il structure notre vie.
Il rythme nos journées.
Métro, boulot, dodo.
Il est dans tous les discours,
politiques notamment.
On nous dit de travailler plus...
pour gagner plus.
Mais il est aussi présent
dans les discours familiaux.
Quand j’étais enfant, mon père,
agriculteur ici en Picardie, nous disait :
« Il faut bien travailler à l’école
pour avoir un bon métier plus tard. »
Et souvent il ajoutait : « Sinon, vous
viendrez traire les vaches avec moi. »
Alors j’ai bien travaillé à l’école,
j’ai fait ce qu’on attendait de moi
et j'ai décroché ce qui est supposé
être un bon métier.
Qu’est-ce que le bon métier ?
Eh bien, l’histoire ne le dit pas.
A priori, pas d’aller traire les vaches.
Mais hormis cela,
je n’avais pas d’autres explications.
J'ai donc observé autour de moi.
J’en ai vu pour qui un bon travail, c’est
un boulot assuré et pas trop fatigant.
Il y en a pour qui le bon travail,
c'est un emploi rémunérateur.
Et pour d’autres, c’est une espèce
de représentation sociale,
une identité,
une image positive et flatteuse
de qui ils sont,
une expression de leur ego, finalement.
« Je travaille, donc je suis. »
Alors si Gérard me demandait :
« Tu fais quoi dans la vie ? »,
j’aurais pu lui répondre :
« Je suis un bon métier. »
Mais sommes-nous des « être » humains
ou bien des « faire » humains ?
Alors longtemps,
j’ai été un « faire » humain,
enferré et tiraillé entre la valeur
que je plaçais dans le travail
et le sens que j’y trouvais réellement.
Une espèce de sentiment amer
de « Tout ça pour ça ? »
Et, en toile de fond,
il y avait cette espèce d’injonction
invisible de la société.
J’étais censée aimer ce que je faisais
puisque j’avais un bon métier.
Alors si je suis honnête avec vous,
travailler eh bien, je préférerais ne pas.
Mais vous aussi, regardez votre voisin.
Une chance sur deux que
celui-ci n’aime pas son travail.
(Rires)(Murmures dans le public)
Je pense que le brouhaha
parle de lui-même.
Et encore pire,
48% des Français déclarent être d’accord
avec l’affirmation suivante :
« L’argent est la seule raison
pour laquelle je vais travailler. »
Alors ne pas aimer son travail
semble banal, mais c’est aussi légitime.
D’abord parce que travailler, ce n’est pas
un plaisir, c’est une contrainte,
une nécessité pour pourvoir à nos besoins.
Et aussi parce que le travail,
ça n’est pas facile tous les jours.
C'est une souffrance.
Sept Français sur dix déclarent avoir
un emploi nerveusement fatigant.
Les troubles musculo-squelettiques
restent la première cause
de maladies professionnelles en France.
Dans ce contexte,
se définir par le travail peut sembler
paradoxal, voire insensé.
Parce que, finalement, on se définit
par une contrainte, une souffrance.
Je pense que ça n’étonnera
personne de savoir
que parmi les quelques étymologies
supposées au mot « travail »,
l’une d’entre
elles serait le mot latin « tripalium »,
un instrument de torture
destiné aux esclaves.
Génial !
D’autres linguistes estiment que
le mot est un dérivé du mot « entrave ».
Voilà, ce n’est pas mieux.
Alors, que faire ?
Face à la souffrance au travail
ou bien la perte de sens,
on peut être tenté de tout quitter,
pour aller traire les vaches,
pour cultiver notre jardin,
mais c’est rarement une option réaliste.
La question est de repenser
notre façon de travailler
pour créer des cadres
et des espaces de réjouissance.
Et c'est justement la proposition
de l'entreprise libérée.
Dans ma vie professionnelle, j’ai pu
collaborer avec ce type d’entreprise.
Alors non, mettre un babyfoot
dans la salle de pause,
ça n’est pas ça, l’entreprise libérée.
L’entreprise libérée veut repenser
la manière de travailler,
offrir plus d’autonomie aux salariés
et les laisser libres de choisir comment
ils travaillent, selon quel rythme.
Plutôt qu’une hiérarchie pyramidale,
on est plutôt dans un système horizontal,
voire circulaire,
dans lequel les interactions se font
de manière beaucoup plus fluide.
Et donc de manière naturelle, les salariés
ne sont plus cantonnés à un rôle,
mais ils sont amenés naturellement
à prendre plus de responsabilités.
C’est la notion clé.
L’entreprise libérée propose de remettre
du sens dans la mission des salariés
et permet ainsi une satisfaction
accrue des salariés,
un engagement mais également des
meilleures performances de l’entreprise.
Je me dis que l’entreprise libérée
peut être une solution pour ces Français
qui déclarent ne pas aimer leur métier.
Mais moi, suis-je prête à être libérée
par un patron libérateur ?
Et vous ?
Est-ce une réelle libération que
d’être affranchi par quelqu’un d’autre ?
Si l’entreprise libérée offre
une réponse possible,
organisationnelle et collective,
ça n’est pas la solution
idéale, mais rien ne l’est.
Alors, quelles sont mes options ?
Quelles sont mes options
à titre individuel
si la réponse collective ne suffit pas ?
J’ai réalisé qu’il fallait que
j’aille cheminer ailleurs
et j'ai suivi d'autres pistes.
J’ai écouté toutes les conférences TED
sur le sujet.
J’ai lu beaucoup de livres sur le travail,
et c’était très très intéressant,
mais aussi très très culpabilisant.
On me disait qu’il fallait
que je trouve ma mission de vie.
Même là, j’avais l’impression
d’être un échec -
je ne sais toujours pas ce que c’est.
Ma mission de vie, finalement,
c’est de vivre, non ?
Un ami m’a conseillé :
« Fais de ta passion ton métier,
comme ça tu n’auras plus jamais
l’impression de travailler. »
Une idée de génie, vraiment.
J’ai donc suivi une formation
pour devenir professeure de yoga.
Et puis, en parallèle de mon travail, j’ai
commencé à enseigner à droite à gauche.
Ma passion est devenue une contrainte.
J’ai donc finalement réalisé enfin
qu’il fallait que j’arrête d’aller
chercher des réponses à l’extérieur,
mais que j’aille chercher,
cheminer à l’intérieur.
J’ai donc entamé un cheminement intérieur,
un voyage exploratoire.
Je trouve que c’est intéressant
que d’autres linguistes - encore -
voient peut-être une autre
étymologie au mot « travail ».
Le préfixe « tra » évoque le mouvement.
Le travail serait une traversée, un
transport, une transformation même.
En anglais, le mot « travel »
désigne le voyage justement.
Et ça, ça me plaît.
Je travaille pour expérimenter,
pour grandir en tant qu’être humain,
pour faire des expériences de vie,
pour cheminer.
Par exemple, faire l’expérience
de collègues à la con.
C’est une expérience comme une autre
qui me permet de cheminer et de grandir,
d’apprendre la patience et la tolérance.
Donc je ne travaille pas pour travailler.
Le travail n’est pas une fin en soi,
c’est juste un moyen,
un moyen d’expérimenter.
Il y a cette phrase issue
du « Prophète » de Khalil Gibran
qui résonne particulièrement :
« Tout travail est vide,
sauf s’il contient l’amour.
Car travailler avec amour, c’est
se relier à l’autre, se lier à soi-même.
Travailler, c’est l’amour rendu visible. »
Finalement, peu importe ce que je fais,
ce qui est important,
c’est comment je le fais.
Et vous, demain ?
Comptable,
boulanger,
banquier,
chef de projet, business manager,
développeur région Europe,
comment pouvez-vous remettre du sens dans
votre travail en étant qui vous êtes ?
Comment pouvez-vous
incarner votre fonction
et transpirer qui vous êtes
dans ce que vous faites,
pour travailler de manière plus
authentique, avec amour finalement,
selon votre authenticité propre ?
Finalement,
je me suis libérée
de la souffrance au travail
en le dédramatisant,
en le considérant pour ce qu’il est :
un simple moyen de.
Aimer ce qu’on fait ou pas
ne définit pas la réussite de notre vie.
Et ça ne me définit pas, moi,
en tant que personne.
Ce n’est pas parce que mon travail
est nul que je suis nulle.
Alors quand Gérard me demande :
« Tu fais quoi dans la vie ? »,
eh bien, finalement, c’est moi qui
décide de l’interpréter comme :
« Quel est ton métier ? »
Le fait que je l’interprète ainsi
en disait long sur la manière dont
j’appréhendais le travail dans ma vie.
Un suspense insoutenable
règne dans la salle.
Vous vous demandez sans doute :
« Mais elle, qu’est-ce qu’elle fait ? »
Je fais le même métier qu'avant,
mais différemment.
Je travaille en ressources humaines.
J'ai créé mon entreprise
il y a quelques années.
Le travail, ce n’est pas toujours facile,
mais je le fais de manière authentique
et avec l’amour que j’ai en moi.
Les questions qui m’ont aidée
dans ce cheminement sont les suivantes :
« Pourquoi je le fais ? »
« Pour qui je travaille ? »
« Et comment ? »
Alors, à la pause qui arrive bientôt
ou au prochain cocktail chez des amis,
quand vous aborderez un inconnu,
demandez-lui : « Qui es-tu ? »
« Qu’est-ce qui te passionne ? »
« Qu’est-ce qui te fait rire ? »
Je pense qu’à ce moment-là, vous toucherez
quelque chose de plus profond
que le faire,
beaucoup plus inspirant, vous verrez
un être, et c’est bien ça l’essentiel.
Quant à moi, je vous laisse,
je vais terminer mon feuilleté.
(Applaudissements)